effectivement le milieu artistique c1
c'est un milieu qui est majoritairement
investis par les femmes dans les études
supérieures d'art de culture à la fac au
conservatoire il ya 60% de femmes il me
semble alors qu'on va retrouver 40 % des
femmes dans le métier donc déjà ici on
voit qu'il ya il ya quelque chose qui se
passe entre les études et le moment
d'intégrer la vie professionnelle c'est
déjà il ya une inégalité à ce moment là
et puis ensuite on va s'apercevoir que
au poste de direction au poste
d'administration aux postes de direction
artistique comme moi je vais faire avec
ma compagnie a de moins en moins de
femmes aux postes des scènes nationales
également et c'est donc on a une vraie
inégalité là qui se met en place qui est
probable alors on peut pointer plusieurs
choses moi je pense et mon ressenti
personnel
il ya une question de confiance en soi
qui épate toujours
facile à avoir quand on commence en tant
que femme on va être amené quand on
décide de monter une structure à avoir
des interlocuteurs qui sont
majoritairement masculin souvent plus
âgés que nous si on commence jeune et
donc il ya quelque chose qui va
s'établir de l'ordre du patriarcat qui
est pas nécessairement conscients et
d'ailleurs qui est pape malveillants
mais néanmoins qui existe qui est là et
donc en tant que femme il va falloir qu
on conquiert une légitimité qui nous est
pas naturelle l'art a toujours été
conjuguée au masculin en tant que femme
de sentir se sentir légitime
artistiquement et ensuite légitime dans
le sens de porter un projet c'est
beaucoup plus complexe parce qu'il va
falloir il ya plusieurs stratégies soit
on va acquérir les outils masculins qui
sont des outils plutôt convexe je vais
de l'avant je dois être productif jo est
efficace
je dois montrer que j'ai confiance en
moi je dois foncer
ou alors on va utiliser les outils plus
féminin
qui sont de l'ordre de
être plus dans l' écoute dans la
communication dans le travail du
collectif
tout ça c'est des si on va pas avec les
outils un peu masculin c'est un peu plus
long c'est un peu plus compliqué et moi
je me suis aperçu de sa non mon parcours
c'est que j'ai mis un
un temps énorme à prendre confiance en
moi asseoir ma légitimité en tant que
femme je pense qu'il faut qu'on a je
pense qu'il faut qu'on arrête de penser
essentiellement par genre mais
aujourd'hui je crois aussi que les
hommes sont coincés dans les rôles qu'on
leur octroie qu'on leur laisse il ya
beaucoup d'hommes qui aimeraient aller
sur
j'aimerais aller ailleurs poussé
ailleurs faire différemment et je crois
qu'il faut qu'on soit allié dans ce
combat l'un est effectivement les
métiers d'art et de culture ça doit
représenter un budget de plus de 20
milliards d'euros
et donc ça pose des questions évidemment
si si c'est ce sont des métiers qui sont
autant financier par l'état les toits de
l'état doit avoir un doit être
régulateur de ces inégalités là moi je
pense qu on a besoin
je pense qu'on a besoin
de reconquérir un peu du terrain mais
c'est un c'est une forme de révolution
de chamboulement qui est déjà en route
toute façon c'est là les femmes sont en
train de prendre la place
on est là on arrive donc soit on nous la
laisse soit ça va être un peu plus
violents et oui en fait aux on y aller
au zoo y aller avec beaucoup de joie
avec beaucoup de plaisir avec
douceur et écoute mais alors voila si je
dis douceur on va dire
la douceur la femme la douceur je pense
que oui on a une capacité à être à une
forme de bienveillance mais qu une
bienveillance complètement professionnel
est tout aussi rigoureuse et je crois
que il faut y aller avec beaucoup de
joie en fait
[Musique]